the sounds of construction in somalia's
capital Mogadishu reverberate across the
city cranes dot its Skyline
if you look anywhere in the city you'll
see new modern multi-story buildings
this is what has been replacing bullets
card houses after Decades of War we have
three floors
buttonsame is Building the tallest
apartment Block in the city he says most
of the units were sold even before they
came into the open markets thousands of
people now Engineers doctors are working
and coming to work for Somalia so all of
those people need this demands and and
imagine uh
the cities expanding I can call one of
the fastest cities in terms of growing
in terms of population
real estate developers are especially
happy with the booming markets they're
breaking ground every other month a few
years ago we wouldn't be standing in the
middle of town like we are now things
have really changed more people are
moving into the city we have spoken to a
property owner who says that his
apartment block is fully sold out
but the cost of renting or buying is
beyond many people's reach because there
are no proper regulations to protect
buyers
runs a restaurant he returned from the
UK in 2019 to a country he laughed when
he was five years old
he says life here is not easy but moving
back was worth the risk of the amount
that it cost me to live in Salzburg one
of the most expensive cities in Europe
and what it does to live in Mogadishu is
very much similar I'm paying nearly 800
for a two-bedroom apartment and internet
is the issue electricity and costs are
quite High
but at the same time I think it's
different and financial lanes for
different outputs come out
thousands of diaspora somalis like
shidane are increasingly making their
way home they say they want to see their
City stand on its legs again Catherine
soy Al Jazeera Mogadishu some